welcome to PAX Prime 2015 where
apparently a time vortex has sucked us
into the past to play new games like
Uncharted 2 mega man Resident Evil zero
and a frat boys funtime a 2006 rock
bands no sir I saw a guy taking a like a
snapshot like a picture of the little
Mad Max ubers they have out in the
street he was taking a picture with his
droid razr like that razor max razor it
happened I see Langille ears eating this
place up I'm out and at PAX Prime
2015 we have an exclusive over here a
robot talk to me
there's no gameplay a fallout I don't
know why they did that to me I don't
know why they were actually like hey
guess what fallouts coming out no
gameplay we're nerds
around cosplay girls who are really
attractive we're gonna have enough blue
balls we don't need to almost think we
can almost play fallout 4 and then not
play fallout 4 but it's ok
I got an exclusive interview yeah why'd
you pass on the dog hump interview and
give it to Palin sounds enough like
Donald Trump Ellen cares it's all in
good political fun and people don't take
me seriously on the youtubes that he
would and I finally found in ladies and
gentlemen we have found Deadpool the
movie star who was killed Pikachu and
his wearing his skin as a hat don't let
the little inflatable one behind you
fool you that's in memoriam to the
actual Pikachu uh comic books you know
if Nintendo wasn't such a if
Nintendo wasn't such a and if they
give the rights over to Marvel Studios
that's all I'm talking about decision
good decision don't give up the park so
gonna zip my mouth again like last time
yeah that baraka abomination have you
murdered him yet yeah yeah it doesn't
exist that didn't happen
I killed every single one of the staff
members even thought of the idea and
they're not even worth wearing their
skins as a hat I'm gonna let you guys in
on a little secret
this isn't Ryan Reynolds this is
actually youtuber mr. reps on
that was a really awkward outro that's
my we still get to play dishonored at
backs no no we don't know gameplay of
that either
not really footage either you just gets
do you get a selfie of the love child of
General Grievous and the skeksi from
Dark Crystal all right no gameplay here
either but I keep talking up those
beginning hello
what were you stroking your dick now I
gotta be on camera I mean this guy was
stroking hit do that again do you feel
better about yourself I feel great about
you too I like the way you stroke all
right we get to play doom this no we
don't get to play doom a good room but
can we play me the games I want to play
we just get to take a picture of the
ex-wife over there but that's it no doom
I don't know why I don't know I just
wanna play I just want to play the games
I wanted to play it facts and there it
is folks that's what we call nonsense
it's not all games it's fun sometimes
it's just fun and nonsense but I hope
you guys had fun
that's my I don't know what I'm even
gonna call this Jeremy jerks around and
does nothing it packs
[Music]